[Música]
oi meu nome é bruno e hoje vou falar pra
vocês de como os robôs impactaram a
mente no futuro
agora vamos vender uma coisa como é que
esse nosso sistema funciona simples o
que acontece o cérebro humano um comando
bruno para mais duas final da medula
espinhal esse comando vai para os nervos
e dos nervos chega ao membro eo
movimento é concluído mas o que acontece
esse sistema for interrompido
aqui são os tipos de lesões que podem
acontecer na sua coluna fazendo você
virar para plástico o tetraplégico
se for a cervical que é mais íntima que
acontece na região do pescoço
você dá dylan é pai de todos os
movimentos do corpo - a cabeça e se for
na automática que é parte da região das
costas
você perde o movimento e da barriga e do
e das pernas e se for na lombar você só
para os movimentos nas pernas o que
torna uma pessoa paraplégica o
tetraplégica na maior parte das vezes o
que acontece um acidente de trânsito mas
também existem casos que o que acontece
são agressão queda mergulho impacto do
objeto e outros o que robótica tem a ver
com isso
simples existe uma máquina feita para
ajudar tetraplégico de paraplégicos a
voltará a mexer os membros
e ela funciona assim o cérebro humano
comando
2 a máquina leva comandar um membro 3 e
por fim a máquina executa o comando
agora vou mostrar um vídeo curto pra
vocês e vou ver o que vou ver o que
vocês acham
esse foi o primeiro chute da copa de
foi o que me fez começar a fazer esse
tema de robótica e até hoje eu faço ele
e agora faz uma última pergunta pra
vocês
shoot cá já auxilia tanto a medicina
como será isso no futuro
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]